cameraman
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
you're a woman
like all right well we're done
[Music]
okay for one minute starting now hi
hello Hi how are you I'm doing great how
are you I'm doing good
what's your name my name's Ryan
[Music]
I do community outreach for a non-profit
it's the Asthma and Allergy Foundation
so he's trying to serve underserved
communities to get access to healthcare
oh it's so great
I have like the smoking around this is
like my grandma well if we need
researchers
that I take your breath away
I would say that's where I wasn't
thinking that no you you're beautiful
though
are you a lifted yes oh it's fun
um
that'd be great yeah I thought the book
user might do it oh I know yeah
[Music]
wow the Sparks are in the air already a
lesbian couple hitting it off uh someone
related to Liz Warren I'm assuming on
the left-hand side anybody Elizabeth
Warren a political candidate what are
your thoughts and feelings is that
because of the Blazer yeah it's a real
formal look right you guys are dressed
for two very different dates it looks
like
oh yeah I don't I feel like it's hard to
I feel like we're both like the mass
killing lesbian you know what I mean
that's what I was trying to go for like
you know stomp your face in
um at the end of the night kind of vibe
hell yeah yeah
I'd do it I don't know
so two uh two tops
how does it work you guys rock paper
scissors at the end of the day uh yeah I
usually land on the scissors though hell
yeah
give it up for her she's doing great
yeah
lesbian Pride or whatever you say uh
that's cool so uh how many uh
how's your how's your life going uh ryer
you recently were on kill Tony was that
a fun experience yeah it was really cool
it's been cool it's been um just a lot
of cavity a lot of like I wanna I wanna
try and date somebody that's why I
thought this might be fun I want to like
uh I'm just bad I'm a virgin I don't
know if you're supposed to say that like
on this sort of thing I don't I'm just
bad with people and I feel like we're
both like the man lesbian and they're
supposed you know they're supposed to be
like a feminine one I don't know so is
that a thing you guys uh all have
different sides you guys you know like
like a Sorting Hat like a lesbian
Sorting Hat
yeah the masculine one the kind of
androgynous uh queer and general fluid
yeah there's like a sleeper like
definitely somebody that like goes with
both
well that's fun it's good to know that
there's divisions even amongst you
people
[Laughter]
which is fine enough love a good lesbo
uh
uh Paul what do you what do you think
about this beautiful lesbian couple
um I think I'm totally in support of it
especially if my boss hears about this
show
um no it was a that was a much that was
less awkward than almost every date I've
ever been on I know which is something
about not having a horny dude in the mix
that really improves the date yeah
because I come out lying straight off
the top you know what I mean that's been
my method but honestly it's uh if men
wanted to talk [ __ ] no no oh we have met
we don't have straight females that's
what we're looking for so is anybody a
straight female in here even is anyone
willing to admit that they're a straight
female
no all right there we go
they're all liberals yeah
you gotta lick whatever's in front of
you
probably me so Mo you working and you
work for underserved communities giving
them Health Care
wow I need health care am I not I'm not
underserved though I'm overserved okay
never mind Check Your Privilege white
man my bad I would like healthcare
though but uh
what got you into that line of work and
when did you become a communist
you're beautiful
that's so great it's so cool Breyer what
do you do I'm a nanny I used to work in
special education and I work as a as a
nanny for kids with uh with special
needs which is cool it's just helping
one child yeah there's two yeah it's the
same two doubling up
they're gross I said I'm sorry I called
them girls oh no it's okay that's very
nice oh they're super gross it's okay so
right
you're a virgin how's that been so far
good I don't know I just feel bad all
the time
just like I don't know how to like do it
or like how you with lesbians I don't
know what like are we ever really not
virgins I still didn't know anything
about it so no big deal there for real I
mean a thousands I got 10 000 hours and
I'm a beginner I don't get it so Paul is
a fan of the land prey
apologize
Oh damn got silence you're canceled
well I can't apologize for being too
fast three lesbians on stage right now
teamed up against you
I uh dated a lesbian comedian in Boston
for a very short amount of time
oh and uh how did that go not well she's
a lesbian comedian now so that's where
that went she was before and after it's
called Hideout comedy that she runs the
show in Boston hide in the closet okay
nice advertisement for your ex they put
a spotlight right on me that's how bad
I'm following right now let's get the
advertising Spotlight so uh Moe's what
uh what how would you uh how would you
tell ryer uh you know the ins and out of
lesbian sex
whoa
don't forget to record it
um what do you want to know what
questions do you have
um
I feel like uh some well sometimes I
wonder like what like you're
like what
maybe like what you're supposed to put
inside
because I feel like what goes where yeah
because sex is always like something you
know something into something right does
it have to be I think so I mean it just
depends on your definition I don't have
one
yeah it's not something I Define I don't
think I don't know maybe I'll just be
like a like asexual I don't know I don't
want to be one of those but maybe I'll
just be like by myself I'll just have a
couple dogs or something
I mean that sounds pretty rewarding in
itself yeah
are you [ __ ] these dogs or
no
no
no
get some peanut butter
I don't know how you have sex with dogs
why are you looking at me right now
if anyone's an expert damn
um no I wouldn't know peanut butter I
seem creamy probably I don't know
I feel like the nuts they could probably
choke on or something like that let's
move on I don't know why you put this on
me I don't even own a dog why am I in
this so right you have asthma how's that
been working out for you oh yeah it's
not bad it's mostly like when I work out
and [ __ ] it's really bad but like in
general it's not horrible great excuse
to not have to work out yeah no I'm just
bad like I love like uh wrestling and
stuff and when I wrestle I just like
start to hyperventilate but then I'm
like really like I don't like using an
inhaler because it kind of gets me high
so then I just like don't use it then I
just like and keep going it's really bad
I think that's what it'd be like in sex
maybe that's why I'm scared I mean yeah
I mean wrestling's pretty much sucks
you're halfway there
wow ryer's getting horny yeah it's just
like can I double leg a [ __ ]
oh that's funny
how's uh how is your wrestling career I
heard you had your is quite illustrious
what's up what was your go-to move maybe
we could translate that into a sexual
move I didn't was good at the duck under
that was my thing duck under I did a
high crotch really well I cried I didn't
even think holy [ __ ] you're already
halfway there to lesbian sex
you already are not a virgin you've
fingered a bunch of dudes [ __ ] I'm
sure dude there's yeah
first of all I was being experience like
um
that's a question
um it was great I mean it was like you
know I could finally like live and be
happy you know because before it was
like I just dated a guy and that was
pretty awful so
um you know men yeah they all look like
Paul so I don't date them turns out
people don't really use dental dams that
was very surprising to me
use a dental man what is a dental dam
it's like damn you love Jesus we have
plastic that you put over
um you know your dinner before you you
go in to eat it I love eating dinner
with a piece of plastic in front of it
Saran Wrap
do you do you always use it
I have never tried oh you've never
fortunately no dental dams were a thing
they were trying to push on us and sex
ed and the South
here's the thing you can do to not be a
dirty [ __ ]
has anyone got show of hands if you use
a dental dam everyone close their eyes
be honest
look at all these enthusiasts honesty
and Truth here okay trust all right
nobody
yeah I don't think I'd want to be with
somebody that used a dental dam
because I feel like you'd feel like
really not like intimate you know what I
mean
yeah I mean
just depends on what you're into if
you're into like eating rappers then you
probably would really like it
look I've made an origami crane inside
your [ __ ]
yeah
well anyways what is your next move if
you guys were to go on a second date
where would it be
[Music]
what do you think what's a good second
date well I've never I don't think I've
ever been on the second date yeah I've
never been on a first and I would say
you know what I'd probably probably go
to probably go to a comedy show I
suppose it would be or or we could get
food
and I like food well food's good yeah
how's your first date going this one
yeah I don't know man it feels I feel
like this is not how it's supposed to be
you know what I mean I don't know I
don't know why you say that right this
is completely natural and organic
experience is very replicable in other
situations
other people name of the show hashtag
yes uh uh I'm doing a great job uh uh Mo
what uh what do you think you like food
wow I like food it sounds like
are we having sex right now
depends on how you define it
uh Mo do you like comedians I do
what uh what comedian is like your
favorite
probably Bay Martin
May Martin damn
I must I don't know maymar is supposed
to be
one of those lesbian so yeah no I don't
know I was gonna say that I would go on
a first date to the movie Jumanji that'd
be awesome Rob Williams
that's a romantic movie I kind of look
like the kid from Jumanji was turning to
a monkey halfway through the movie so
maybe that's why I have a little bit of
South Park my heart production not only
does he own an ape nft he looks like one
too I'm killing it
anyways we still got these lesbians on
the stage I think they're as great I
think it was great chemistry I would be
in support of a second if you if you
feel like it's awkward you can come to
any Dive Bar in the city I will get
drunk in the corner and watch your
second date as well
we will be commenting on it yeah the
binocular
um but yeah no a great date hopefully a
woman signs up because we just got a
bunch of straight males but uh yeah
thank you for coming up Mo and ryer
cameraman
foreign
[Applause]
cousin of Stevo
here he comes any women want to
volunteer right now is your chance he's
a tall man it's okay if you have a
boyfriend
is just for pretend
um
who doesn't want to go on a date with
him maybe Jacka
oh here she comes
a human female
wearing a sweatshirt from the Kanye West
collection Jacka one minute starting now
that was a nice formal introduction so
bright it is oh you got mushrooms
no it's sometimes that happens with the
with the bright lights that's why I was
wondering okay so you talk a lot no go
ahead
it's very bright yes well Hans like
announced my entire name so uh what's
what's your name my name's chaddo Shadow
yeah see he didn't know my entire name
so yeah I can see why let's not bomb
this are you a fan of magicians do you
like magic at all
uh yeah I'm gonna show you a trick okay
all right let's keep this going
I found this a happy face deck earlier I
thought it'd be a cool little thing
she's scared
all right look they all have happy faces
on them
you guys see that
regular deck
faces happy faces all right
I'm gonna go through here you tell me to
stop okay
just like that okay stop
end time finish the trick
do I have to touch it
all right
I saw it it's a real card I think
make a gun
like with my hand
yeah sound effects look at that
or look for your card
did you see your card
oh it's in here I know it's in here all
right this is a great track hold on it's
a great trick let's see if I can find it
though
hold on oh my God it's taking a while
uh Shadow is a resident magician they're
on their fourth date by now in this
standard
they're moving in together oh wow
there's a red mark on the card
he put a red mark on it somehow
it's a hole oh man put a little hole on
it he's already yes it is my card wow
it's for five of clubs wow a card trick
on a date thank you thank you that's how
I break the eyes I'm so impressed I'm
glad you had to bring your own deck what
was your name again
Stevo Chad oh right shadow
please thank you is that um so is that
your like career do you no I don't have
a career I'm a magician no no he's like
I don't want to bomb this do you like
magic
I like magic the Gathering oh cool hell
yeah maybe some dungeon dragons there we
go I like the little dungeon action okay
check uh what's the weirdest thing
someone's done on a date and is it magic
um that was the weirdest thing someone's
ever done on that how did it make you
feel
um
pretty cocky about myself uh really see
there you go it made me feel like I'm
like too good to Shadow how often does
this work uh this is not worked yet I've
tried twice oh let's do another trick do
you have any other tricks
I I have a few tricks but I don't want
to steal the whole show you said I was
talking too much I won't give you some
time oh okay so what do you do
I have five jobs wow I have no jobs and
this chick has five I don't yeah you are
overcoming yourself we don't even need
to be here for this he's just on his own
what is uh your top five top of the five
on top of the five yeah
well everyone has to have a job right I
don't think so so I'm a realtor
full-time oh well okay a screenwriter
actor yoga teacher oh yeah
you know what I am three of those four
things oh what are you well I'm a
mortgage broker I'm a writer you're a
mortgage magician Joker okay so you do
have a career yeah well
and I'm a director they're falling in
love all of a sudden he had he had to
say the mortgage and I was like okay
yeah so I'm also a director too oh wow
what do you direct your magic tricks I
do I I make a little stage magic every
once in a while but no I I write and
direct uh action comedy things like that
could you see me in any of the your
roles
I can see you in one of them
what did you think of Shadow when you
first met him
the basic white guy I'm right here
Shadow so what is the whitest thing
about you my dick how white is your dick
Barry it's almost pink
is it like not that big
well I mean I don't know compared to
Asians it is but it's okay so not that
big yeah you're on the same page I
mentioned earlier that I lived in
Southeast Asia for two years so I'm
gonna have to see this to all right
pull it out let's do this find out let's
see how pink it really is
yeah I don't know not the pink part but
the size part I think you're yeah I
don't know Shadow uh so you have a white
dick thanks for explaining that and then
roasting me for my rice [ __ ] you you
white supremacists
Shadow uh I hate you uh Jacka what do
you think about uh chatto now like do
you like think differently of him
I would like to take him on a second
date actually oh God just so I can see
that pink small thing that he's talking
about just so I can take a picture and
then send it to you and you can be like
no I'm much better yeah yeah we'll
compare dicks Shadow what is the best
thing about your dick
man why we keep on going back to this
you brought it up [ __ ]
so the wise thing about me and we keep
on going back to it yeah you're the one
that brought Asians into it oh okay I'm
in it now have you ever done a magic
trick involving your dick yeah I can
make it like a third day okay that's
like a
maybe third or fourth day type of thing
if you guys were gonna Netflix and chill
what movie produced to watch respectable
question I'm okay I like I feel like
they're both gonna have great answers
well I have some go-to's oh what's a
go-to not that I've would you say
Netflix and chill or whatever children's
they haven't had sex in years I don't
like go I don't bring men back to my
house but um if I were to
would well that wouldn't happen I have
some go-to's that I would personally
watch and if someone else wanted to
watch them with me I might think that
they were cool it would be I didn't
expect this answer to be this long when
I did it
yeah the Labyrinth
Pan's Labyrinth there's some magic dance
magic dance a lot of Puppets
a lot of magic going on all right they
were falling in love all of a sudden
again let's ruin it all right what else
oh I have to keep going oh well okay I
would like my go-to is like Pulp Fiction
or clerks something a little bit more
talky so I can just not talk oh wow so
you just show me your dick yeah oh wow
okay I get it now I know what Netflix
and chill actually means yeah so uh
Labyrinth not a lot of talking elaborate
a lot of visuals well I'd just be really
high in like singing all the words the
entire time so
if she was on mushrooms I did I I sensed
it do you think that she's on mushroom
what makes you think she's on mushrooms
you're weirdo does the audience think I
think everybody knows about mushrooms
now
she's on mushrooms I feel like I'm on
mushrooms
the state is [ __ ] oh come on
come on I already got a second date
don't feel it kill it no my bad yeah
after this I think
every clothes piece of clothing you have
on is blue right now I just want you to
know that are you on mushrooms
are you vibrant I want some mushrooms
Vibes yeah
you look like a retired police officer
uh Jacka what does your experience with
the law have you ever been arrested
Jesus Christ well you had to say my
whole name when I first walked up here
Google and find this out
yes like six times excited to know six
times six or seven for how many
different things a lot that's the
blackest thing about you
that yeah part of it what what did you
get arrested for ah
um
mostly being extremely [ __ ] up in
places that I probably shouldn't be like
I don't know hell yeah white girl
arrests
I remember the first time I was arrested
laughing
funny trip down memory lane oh
yeah the first time it was I actually
got roofied I was drinking a virgin pina
coladas and I got roofied
and you got arrested and I called the
cops
or no no I didn't call it I don't know
what happened this tracks was mostly
police departments I went to jail
there's one time I broke out of jail
though and that was funny
you broke out I did well how did you
break out of jail South Padre Island
so
I grew up as a homeless child since I
was 14 so when I was like 18 I talked to
my dad for the first time I was like hey
it's almost your birthday like
let me take you on a trip and we'll
we'll see how it goes well it went and
then how did you get arrested I fell
asleep outside of my hotel because I
gave everyone else the key to the suite
so I was like sleeping and these cops
were like poking me and telling me I
needed to go with them
how did you escape
um so they put me in like a drunk take
in South Padre Island and then the cop
like left because the root I mean the
jail was smaller than it was pretty damn
small and uh next thing I know
my brother and my stepbrother walk in in
their swim trunks soaking wet
no police are there and there's keys on
the wall and I'm in this tank and I'm
like dude
right there and they get the keys they
unlock the door and I leave and then we
went um bungee jumping
after that her full name is Jacob
Beecher she has wanted in South Padre
Island that's been broadcasted to
YouTube right now I actually called I
was pretty scared I called like two
months later and I was like yeah um this
is
wondering if there was a warrant out and
they were like no no record
I think they threw it away because the
cops shouldn't have left me in there
alone so when he came back from doing
whatever the [ __ ] he was doing and I
wasn't there well I'm glad that you
didn't let anyone else out but yourself
you selfish there was no one else there
it was so small
well congratulations you got away with
uh that's awesome yeah yeah well uh you
know being white is awesome you wasn't
sure if you're a black person they would
have been looking for you like a black
cut out no I'm sure that uh you did a
great job Escaping The Prison Shadow
what is uh your experience with the law
are you a fugitive per chance
no I have not
um I'm bored I've been tied into stuff
but I I try to be a good boy I think I
might be overqualified for this date now
after hearing some of these uh answers
but no I'm kidding uh no I've uh
can I get better oh you guys look like
you would run a great trailer park
together
[Music]
modern siding on all of them don't steal
my purse because I forgot where I left
it we have HOA rolls canopies in the
driveway to protect your car from leaf
and litter there's rules but yeah yeah
you guys uh look like you could be in a
Will Ferrell movie together oh there we
go is that our future
oh okay we can do that RV Park
yeah there it is let's continue going to
jail the trailer home shadow what race
are you what country are you from I am
from America but uh here being born in
Chicago you're either polish or Russian
you don't know I do not know you're
Eastern European yeah uh Jacka what is
your uh experience with dating outside
of your race
why do you always tell my girls
there was one person that I kind of
wanted to go on a date with that was out
of my race but then he told me he had a
girlfriend that lived in San Antonio so
I never went on a date with him
unfortunately wow very specific thanks
for uh I don't uh I don't really know I
did I did date a guy from Pakistan once
and he had like this long black hair and
I thought he was like a Greek god
and then when I found out he was from
Pakistan I was like oh I guess that's
cool and like I still dated him it was
fine oh my God he's such a race no I did
and then I found out he was married with
kids and then I was like okay now I can
really dump you like now I have a reason
God damn so yeah that's my that's my
experience Not only was he Pakistani
he was packing a family but in my mind
he was a long black-haired Greek god
thank you thank you from the back
Shadows Applause from the back hacking a
family
Checker so how was that experience would
you uh ever recommend dating uh
Pakistani ever again
I can't do
it yes yes you should you should date
whoever all the time
all the time okay just like Shadow thank
you Shadow have you ever dated a
Pakistani I have not but uh when it
comes to the gentle dance I do want to
know what every race tastes like so I
would not use one either that would be
an interesting it was a far away man
thing to say going around tasting
people's vaginas there it is
what have you noticed what have your
scientific studies found Shadow uh so
far your robust sample size so far that
uh
there's a there's no distinct uh
difference okay well who would I know
I'm Gonna Keep On researching though but
so far keep at it yeah the sample size
is about one I'm assuming no no it's 12.
I don't know
the number written in his phone
Chad uh what's the youngest child you've
ever I mean sorry woman you've ever
dated good Lord because you do magic
tricks when I was 16 I dated my uh I
don't know as an adult like what's the
youngest you've ever dated so that was
my point I always had older older women
and I never really did Magic until this
this age
okay so you like older women yeah it's
always been older chicks for me for some
reason
yeah he likes his women like he likes
his magic old and outdated there it is
yeah
what uh so you mostly date older women I
do actually it's not by choice it's by
their choice I think
yeah two chooses me
yeah
we're still at gunpoint today that was
not your choice yeah like eat this [ __ ]
right now all right
Shadow have you ever been forced to eat
[ __ ] before supposed to say a good
point yeah it has happened it's not
happen to you is that not a thing so
glad I decided dude don't worry about it
have you ever been arrested I have been
arrested what for I went to go help some
guy collect money from some other guy
and you're in the mob they assumed I was
the muscle you were in the Polish or
Russian mob in Chicago I have no record
uh but I have been arrested hell yeah
dude only once just the one time
if you owe money you owe money you got
to get that money you gotta get that
money so what were you doing on this
debt collection I was standing there
looking menacing that was that was my
gig so you were an accomplice I was and
apparently I was too menacing because
this when we went to go pick it back up
the cops were waiting for us
so yeah yeah he had called the cops the
cops were waiting there he told him I
had a gun the only reason the cops would
actually come which I did not have a gun
but I did think about bringing one the
second time which is like kind of a
weird thing it's just out of yeah but I
did not so you were an organized crime
maybe Rebecca do you think you're too
good for this guy now he doesn't even
have a job
I made money absolutely too good
okay
like 10 times better than me
oh that's hard yeah I mean I don't think
I'm like aesthetically extremely hot but
like I know what's up here and I know
what's in my bank account and I know
it's like I need 10x of that yeah I need
someone who's like yeah I got a baby
I got it Shadow what is the most
impressive thing about you
not my bank account
um not I don't know besides your
mustache you like that
that's good man no I uh so the most
impressive thing about me was I've uh I
actually wrote 16 screen plays in
Hollywood I was option five times and
never made a movie
never made a movie never made a movie
okay that's the most impressive thing
what screenplay you're most proud of
what what screenplay are you most proud
of uh it's called story of a gun pitch
it to me right now it's about this
badass Desert Eagle gold-plated gun and
tells in five chapters it follows this
gun through each uh person's hand and
how they all tie together
I can't imagine why liberal Hollywood
didn't want to take that movie from him
that's one of them welcome to Texas you
belong here yeah you wrote a story about
a gun I could pitch more but that was my
favorite because it's a pretty action
field
oh yeah well I guess we do have one
thing in common I'm also a screenwriter
but my movies are good oh how many have
you made you both have the same amount
of movies that have been greenlit to be
filmed yeah
they both are as successful you've
written I have some made feature films
but I have options 16 full features and
uh actual teams Abraham Lincoln lost his
first runner 16 times but he kept up
with it you'll be good that's better
than me I've only worked okay I heard
you're a rapper dude would you like to
rap for us a little bit oh she went
right to it
um
I could I could tell like the the sound
guy to put my music on
put my music up to us we're actually
down
somebody's a fan you got a fan out there
we still need females to sign up that's
what we're doing in the show by the way
yeah if anyone else wants to date Chad
oh there's a whole bunch of guys well
why don't we get another man up here
today there you go now if another one
get a drink for that there you go check
uh would you like to date again I love
you give it up for a shadow
does anybody have a vodka oh
we're gonna get another man up here
my armpits are getting sweaty
maybe you're right about the white
people smell thing give it up for a Naim
b-day boy
Nadeem going on a date with jekka
I already have a better feeling Shadow
here we need another woman up here are
we allowed to drink up here where's my
drink
hi hey doing
you smelled a lot
I smell a lot is it no it's good it's a
good smell it's just like a lot okay
I kind of feel offender because she was
talking about the Pakistani thing you
know
hello
it's very nice
okay yeah
yeah
cologne nice
um but yeah what about pakistanis
I don't know
so is that where you're from no I'm not
um yeah I was gonna be like round two
yes
it's gonna be the winner
yeah so uh so you do uh real estate
real estate yeah yeah oh okay uh-huh
cool I actually have a condo off uh
Sixth Street we could go to if this
works out oh okay it's listed so I mean
probably oh thanks oh come on man wow
Shadow you know what
hold on what was your name again and
time go to French
that was cold-blooded by Channel what
the hell
shout out so remember me it's uh
Instagram
um Nadeem what did you think about the
day now your name Naim
um I don't know I took my first time
coming on stage it's just uh it's just
like a new thing so I don't know
um I think you're doing great bro it's
just like you know the lights what did
you think about her comments about
pakistanis just give it to her straight
um I think it was just fair enough you
know the guy was uh you know packing
with the family so yes that was Shadow's
joke
name the episode packing with the family
police Lizzy packing with the penis as
well Checker did he have a big hog a
little Pakistani AK-47
he only ate hello
what does that mean does that mean
anything to you Naim oh it means a lot
yeah I mean
it's the way that um you think that
[ __ ] halal [ __ ] you say hello
do you think well you have to slaughter
it first to be Halal you know oh hell
yeah we don't slide up with that big old
D you just jumped in the first place sir
in this dating pool
what is it good you just jumped into
first place in front of Chad oh here
Chad buy another drink
what race do you think he anything
racist you want to say to Naim right now
yeah bring up where you're from so she
can [ __ ] all over a guy she dated in the
past
hold on where are you from
uh I'm originally from Jordan but uh
yeah I'm half Palestinian half Syrian
it's hot
okay a bunch of countries that Americans
know nothing about I cannot pick it up
on a map I don't even know what part of
the world
I think he's South American
I've been to actually no I've been to 19
countries but not yours so it gives me
something new to experience if you want
to take me there what is the closest you
got to Jordan like
from those 19 countries
too drunk for that I got an autograph
from Jordan one time
sorry I couldn't resist
what is uh what do people in Jordan
think about Michael Jordan
I I think I think the only thing that we
know about Michael Jordan is that you
know
uh you remember that Looney Tune that uh
yeah yeah like that movie that's how I
knew Michael Jordan so really yeah so he
went that far you know got a movie yeah
I know what movie is the country of
Jordan been in
what is it again
what's uh well who do you think has been
in a better movie Michael Jordan or the
country of Jordan
well well there is no there is no
country
exactly my country Michael Jordan
forever is there an airline called Air
Jordan in Jordan possible
uh
um I like to fly that
like Mike are you wearing Jordans now
Nike yeah yeah that's not brand loyalty
right there yeah those are Nikes
basic uh I don't know
no it's not trying to look cool you know
a little bit but it's not hard to be one
of the better dressed men on the show
right now I gotta be honest dude looking
great you look you both look beautiful
for your first day so you guys are
beautiful I just want to let you know
that thank you yeah Rebecca what do you
think about uh the country of Jordan
anything to say no
okay
um anyways Jordan is a great country
um I think that's great uh have you uh
ever what would what would what do you
think that people in Jordan would say if
you took away girl say like jeka back
home would they be like wow good job man
or would they be like how dare you bring
this white devil into well I mean if I
told her to Jordan I will cover your ass
I'm not gonna I mean it's really it will
really be rare it will be really rare to
find like I mean that's a great pickup
line hey come back home to Jordan with
me I'll cover your I'm the jealous guy
you know so yeah you're the jealous guy
yeah I am a jealous guy I'm jealous
Jordan over here
jealousy in Jordan
um so what kind of burka would you put
her in some of that uh slim fitting
burka would it means America were to be
a half burka because I used to live in
Malaysia so I know the difference like I
know I think it will just you know just
put um like a scarf on on her head and
you say you're gonna put chloroform
[Music]
it doesn't have to be black or could it
be like hot pink
I got you okay so it doesn't matter wow
did I put like contacts
so Jaco what uh what do you think about
uh
all this would you love to go on a
vacation to the Middle East
or a scarf Rider had the entire time
I mean I'd be down for a little while
you know uh she doesn't really have to
wear anything when she go there uh to
put it yeah oh my God that's even more
sexual
cover
of your hair just the ankles
an
um
that's a 16th century
pieces of every other country uh what
what would you say if you saw Jeff his
ankle right now is that something that
you would be willing to do inject it and
show this
um
okay I think yeah it doesn't matter how
your caps do you have a nice cast
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
actually
it's funny I always been into uh blonde
woman so I lose a lot of them here which
is
and covering
Jack uh are you happy to hear that being
a blonde that uh that Naim is basically
helpless in front of you
okay
babe uh what do you have to say to
blonde people everywhere is there a word
of encouragement you like to give people
yeah yeah
oh yeah um like look into my eyes and
like tell me something that's it yeah
yeah just the state just stay the Way
You Are
to stay born
no not yet all right
we'll stay alone and keep it real this
tastes a lot to carry on okay all right
everybody's in a stroke at the same time
on the stage
well naive thank you for being on
stageco let's uh get another woman up
here yes
[Applause]
[Applause]
here she comes Victoria I'm going on a
day with naive from Jordan
[Music]
one minute starting now
pretty good please Hi how are you pretty
good yeah a little fun yeah
yeah it's like nice
it's kind of the burnt orange
I'm not from Texas
[Music]
yeah my assistant
[Music]
so where are you from
um from Memphis oh okay yeah what
purpose looks like it's like Austin you
know you know that's not okay oh yeah
yeah
hey man uh how long have you been today
uh seven years
[Music]
yeah
I lived in New Jersey for three months
yeah
and time
give it up for Victoria
[Applause]
um
yeah yeah it's a nice it's a nice city
there I mean I was I was maybe like I
was the only I would say I was the only
air up there and the problem oh it
wasn't a problem
it was it was there was a lot of
um you know I'm Jewish you know because
when you go there you have a conflict
between Palestine so for me it's like
when you see that it's like you see
other people that you could always see
them on TV right and you're like I'm
moving to Texas right I was like I have
no problem with y'all you know let me
you know let me write that 7-Eleven
thing you know just let me get that
special
wow I think they're being racist to
yourself yeah
7-Eleven I mean
what brings you to Austin Texas Victoria
yeah
[Music]
I've lived in Texas
I have some some people here so yeah
well welcome to Texas thank you have you
uh jot a gun yet
um I have before when I was like oddly a
kid I guess yeah but I lived in Indiana
you're from the Middle East and you've
been to a couple weddings
ourselves there you know so maybe I'll
pull myself twice
I did not make a suicide best joke and
he did that to himself
um are you both from Austin
he's already has nicknames for his
regular presidential candidate
uh Victoria what's it like growing up in
Massachusetts uh could you uh rob anyone
here tonight
today what do you think you could Rob
someone tonight if you want to yeah
because you're from Massachusetts
[Music]
the town Ben Affleck okay
there's a lot of things around my
Walmart have a good day anyways
I didn't grow up there I lived there for
the first two years of my life my dad
still lives there and but uh but yeah I
love math I go back to visit you know
about there but I know so I started yeah
any uh any questions about Massachusetts
would like to
ask to see if she's really from there
where are they from uh from central
Massachusetts I'm from like Worcester
Massachusetts
[Music]
um
what's your favorite Adam Sandler movie
oh you're gonna ask the same question
yeah do you know Adam Sandler yeah yeah
they do um
Adam Sandler
um
but he's like our Tony shalu
[Music]
Victoria if you had to show this uh
beautiful Middle Eastern man uh you're a
perfect Adam Sandler movie did it
familiar with the culture which Adam
Sandler movie would it be what does it
say about you as a person
a loaded question
um
but like everything comes to mind
because like you guys really like to be
there anymore
she's a favorite fish said Massachusetts
yeah
uncut gems like Jordan do they what's
the Steelers okay I won't ask it better
or not oh come on Paul all right
circumcision with Jordan right there oh
yeah or nay
[Music]
yeah okay in Canada not so much
um
Paula's Canadian he's bragging about his
intact Venus French Canadian all right
I'm a fresh Canadian America he has no
idea the uh discipline that it takes to
tug your penis every night
uh Victoria have you ever been with a uh
uncircumcised man before
I don't know where to go from here
I'm sorry I let us here I feel like
that's good to know honestly just for my
records
Victoria what is like uh the craziest
first date that you've ever been on
aside from this one of course
[Music]
I was supposed to go on first day in my
younger brother
um his him and his girlfriend got in a
fight and she was like going to college
like three hours away and
I had to basically go pick him up and
and I came with me which is nice and our
first date was like six hour round trip
car ride at nine and um
exciting yeah
a couple that comes together stays
together
um that's for let me came with you you
said entertainment
that's great that's a beautiful date
have you uh would you ever do that for a
girl would you ever be like oh you have
to go six hours let me just
get in a car and she's driving by the
way
did you cover it up or not that's very
important how covered
man that's a little six I don't know um
like what day is it all week
going are we going like to Utah or are
we going to like San Diego you know
so yeah oh yeah
very nice very uh thank you for the oil
by the way that she used for her trip
oil oil
in another
one
hey what do you what do you think about
Asian people do you think like maybe
um I think I think 18 people are
very serious you know very passionate
about what they do yeah strangle
and we gotta stick together
I'm not gonna go six hours
so how did that relationship end up
turning out did you end up dating him
no we went on like two other dates so it
was a bad decision about that guy
didn't even get to date you so what uh
what what is the weirdest thing you said
on the road trip I don't think he said
anything wrong yeah it was very nice
yeah
I wish I feel like I probably have had a
crazier first date but it's not coming
to mind right now I have like a bit of
State trip so this is like kind of like
it's not not a lot of people okay
[ __ ] on the podcast she's currently
on [ __ ]
luckily we got a small audience for you
all right thanks fantastic just like a
circumcised penis
it's an art show it's artistic
name where uh where do you think you
would take Victoria on a date if you
have to take him somewhere
she was like I don't know you pick
um I'd like to make it simple you know
uh just maybe uh oh I like to think so
I'll make a cook a nice soup and uh have
a nice view and a cold night soon
it's a sexy meal at all
you have a nice views
to come over with the flu
I got soup
all the sexy Middle Eastern parties
shoes
and I had a nice Europe
and it's Falafel yeah Europe that's the
thing Euros is free yeah I like to
prepare a horse or a cold
becoming or my ass
beat
honestly any meal that someone cooks for
me like I don't care if it's soup or
whatever
yeah
I can't cook at all I made uh chicken
nuggets to my girlfriend in the air
fryer earlier so I don't know what the
[ __ ] yeah what's wrong with the good
American chicken nugget Victoria
getting camel suit with this building
I guess
Victoria what's the what would you cut
what's your go-to meal for a date
um
I love coffee
I make a really good like fettuccine
alfredo I do like a passion cream sauce
Alfredo you know how much naive let's
blondes he even loves it and it's pasta
that's a good one I like that
oh gosh it's very uh visual yeah name
anything you'd like to say to this white
woman before you leave
man I I think your boyfriend with her
oh she she came on a date yes I think
yeah good luck good luck with the date
yeah who is this what is the relation to
this man is this a is this a day why
don't we have that date on stage hey PJ
I don't want to run the show I'm not
DJ famous celebrity Hans cam but
he doesn't seem like he wants to his
body language it's not
open to this he's got body language like
me right now
well thank you for bringing a date onto
your date uh yeah is this a fantasy of
yours sir just see you later this is his
idea nothing wrong with that there's not
well uh yeah I mean hopefully you guys
uh work it out you know maybe you could
do some time sharing sort of uh our
Arrangement you know Tuesday Wednesdays
uh but yeah thank you guys so much for
coming on stage give it up for Victoria
and naive
human couple
[Applause]
let's go straight here pick a woman out
of the bucket and get a woman out of the
buckets
here we go we got chan and Lexi Chan and
Lexi coming up on stage and Alexa here
she comes Lexi
and Chan
I do not see Chan
try to get my asian brothers some luck
some opportunities
can I get this playlist
making some chicken nuggets for my
girlfriend when we get home a Caucasian
Chan throw this bad boy off going on a
date with Liz Lexi
where are you gonna look and go hi yeah
or thanks good what's your name my name
is Tommy or Chan Chan
are you from Austin uh unfortunately no
I'm from Kansas oh cool nice stuff where
are you from I'm from Canada Canada yeah
Toronto Toronto yeah goodness look at
you yeah not Asian no no good fight
English
so how's it going uh pretty solid pretty
solid can you do your best uh Canadian
accent whatever you're ordering like
some poutine be like can I have a double
double a double double that's it Tim
Hortons coffee drink okay I was trying
to be Canadian there's some gravy in
there yeah
yeah
fair enough yeah 200 born raised how did
you get to Austin
um my boyfriend's job we got moved down
here
um yeah what what made you come to
Austin uh uh lived in California for
like three years
and good taxes were crucial so here I am
yeah same that's why a Canadian
complaining about American taxes you
call me [ __ ]
I've learned a lot about first dates
here here's another thing that you want
to do you want to say what race is your
date is not
a liar
Tommy Chan
Tommy Chan later it's my birthday but
but uh my friends call me Chan okay
likely story
this is the same logic that that uh
jacka's brother used to break her out of
jail all right just go grab the keys
yeah just grab the Chan right you
probably killed an Asian guy and just
took his spot on stage
it's like jetly is the one you just take
over gently no okay they didn't
investigate it's okay
uh Tommy you said uh throw somebody Chan
you said throw some gravy on there
that's your impression of a Canadian
have you had poutine before yeah yeah so
you'd have the shittiest food possible
you could throw some gravy on there it's
[ __ ] amazing yeah he's talking a lot
of [ __ ] right now I appreciate it if you
had a date what would you make so we
were talking about food earlier that's a
good thing if you had a date going over
what would your be your meal that you
would make it was just like a first
dinner like a fourth date
um
it's a good question let's it's like a
third day third day
oh Jesus I guess I would have to YouTube
something
okay and then uh you know probably use
I mean so it's like would you ever cook
soup
certainly not whoever you said that
previously [ __ ] you okay we're divided
on the soup thing right don't be
culturally insensitive this is a
microcosm of our country as a whole we
need to come together okay
yeah it's a great uh before ground whoa
like Shih Tzu oh shitty place that's why
I'm here in Austin what what color are
your eyes Chan you have interesting
color eyes uh a hazy blue hazy blue we
have a lot of blue-eyed people are you
picking only blue eyed people out of the
bucket
[Music]
green blue yeah so Lexi yeah you said
that your version of a Canadian accent
was a double double a egg so double
double is like a Tim Hortons coffee
order it's fun
stereotypical Canadian I was trying to
play into the stereotype
you uh didn't sound very Canadian no
like you were saying double double in
there
no house house what's the most Canadian
thing about you
that I'm from Canada
I was born in Canada
um
I don't know I'm nice
um
I don't know I always use my blinker
Paul do you think uh Lexi is pretty
Canadian in your book I've been I've
been faking it the whole time I I was
born in Boston Massachusetts and I mean
my family's French Canadian so
yeah my my family actually she's being
racist it's fine and we're just doing
Canadian racism right now maybe the
trashiest type of people in the whole
North American continent and I've
accepted it uh my parents were from they
found out they had some family like four
generations back with the same Tiny Town
in Canada so I actually had to get blood
tests to make sure that I was not inbred
which I'm not
congratulations I read the YouTube
comments I know what people are saying
I'm not in red completely thanks man
normal genetically
uh so uh when did you move away from
Canada my boyfriend got a job and so we
moved to California and then he got
relocated to Austin so she has a
boyfriend yeah sorry there he is sorry
beautiful Canadian man how does this
make you feel this Canadians bringing
their women with them is that a racist
stereotype I mean they're just
infiltrating our grounds this this is
all over America
our country
[ __ ] they're women I have no rates
here so don't worry I can't work or Vote
or anything I'm just just here just the
way we like it I can but I don't
yeah a lot of people we are pretty much
American you don't have a job and you
don't vote exactly foreign
so she has a boyfriend unfortunately you
will be walking away with a dry dick
that's okay
I might be able to see you this short
short situation You're Gonna Go are you
flashing anybody
Jesus the most skin on the stage from
having an angle there yeah
what is uh most amount of money you made
in a single day a single day
uh
uh I used to play online poker so it's
wait
why would you ask that question because
you look like you have a lot of time to
live frivolously
short shorts
because I'm racist and you're white ah I
see I see uh you know it's yeah
we like to surmount those victories you
played poker so you made a lot of money
playing poker uh day to day you win a
lot you lose a lot overall did you lose
money or what I'm with several uh fellow
online poker players wow and is Doug
poke here oh no Douglas poke all right
well I don't care I don't care about any
of you Doug focuses so that's an inside
poker thing is David negranu here oh
that guy that guy sucks balls my brother
is a poker player he bought a house
recently and had a child my brother he's
a pro poker player did he win the child
in a poker game he doesn't play online
anymore he plays live but anyway it's a
uh kind of a quarter Korean niece now so
nice Korean yeah we're gonna believe him
just like we believe I won't show
pictures of anybody Canadian I'm in the
group now
Master race right over here me and Hans
whoa
Lexi what do you think about the uh the
Canadian and American politics where do
you lie in terms of that I don't really
pay attention I mean oh yeah you are
American it's like just entertaining so
like Canadian politics doesn't really
affect me because I live here in
American politics I have no saying
because I can't vote so it's I don't
know I can't really do much about it so
then who do you call uh offensive names
then just people comedians
what did you dress up for as Halloween
something racist like Trudeau
no I didn't dress up for Halloween yeah
that was boring you're not American it's
an American holiday I guess is it what
uh why did you dress up for Halloween
were you uh sick with covid uh no we
were just last minute we were gonna
dress up our dog and then we honestly
just didn't get around to it so we're
gonna dress up as dogs no we were gonna
dress up our dog for Halloween and we
just honestly didn't we're gonna dress
it up as a potato
there was some gravy on there
wow
we didn't get around to it though we
were just lazy honestly
what kind of dog is it it's a mini
golden doodle
oh my God you guys are American
yeah so that's cool yeah keeping your
dog around not eating it like I would no
because I'm Asian got him
Chad
what is the most Asian thing about you
and don't say your dick
uh I mean I'm good at math
and I'm also uh very anti-social
I like the ability to form good bonds
with friends what do you think about us
we have very strong bonds I would die
from my Empire
with those outside of my culture
okay yeah we're very insular yeah
Chan uh if you had to uh impress a woman
right now what would you say about your
poker winnings
uh
long
sturdy
and girthy I suppose okay
I think Lexi is sticking with her
boyfriend yes I mean yeah so there's a
few things you can never date a girl
that date that has a golden doodle
oh
why
I mean if if they're gonna buy something
for three thousand dollars
hahaha
and not adopt oh
then maybe wow the crowd just turned I
don't know they love them now they like
you know how to get austinite's dogs
that's all they don't care about more
than people that'll make you more
likable than a Canadian yeah
this douchey yeah
it's connecting with the Liberals
that's true this is politicization at
its at its finest
so uh who did you vote for in the last
election
uh all read locally and then left State
and yeah it's it's unfortunate hell yeah
yeah you have the uh voting record you
have the voting record of your eye
contact intensity yeah see right very
intense get a little uh red blue uh
purple Q
Yeah well yeah I'm uh pretty much a
communist but uh yeah that's fine
really except [ __ ] the homeless yes I
don't remember you saying that actually
don't put that on him Lexi what do you
do with your homeless I don't see a lot
of them kicking around up there Toronto
Toronto is so well I guess not compared
of Austin Austin has a lot of homeless
people but yeah has quite a bit of
homeless people but then the winter
kills them a couple of friends whoa the
winner kills them oh no there's less
yeah okay that's we'll we'll take that
under consideration
it's a good strategy well give it up for
Lexi and Chan allegedly they win a day
we got time for one more one more
pick a man
pick a woman
we got Joe less Jocelyn and Mike
Jocelyn up on stage
Mike Here Comes Mike
okay Jocelyn is not here Jocelyn you
signed up twice
is not here picking another straight man
for the date yeah let's get another
straight man up here
unless the woman wants to go up
Leah
Jocelyn why don't you just come on up
here yeah
she's it takes a lot
thank you
hello
hi what's your name I'm Jamie Jamie nice
to meet you what's your name my name's
Mike Mike yes how's it going it's going
pretty well that's good that's good
what's a what's on your hat what's that
snowflake uh well you know I I'm I'm a
bit of a snowflake so I tend to wrap it
okay okay I mean that could go a couple
different ways I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna run too far with that uh it's a
Avalanche safety uh organization I went
to a fundraiser and I thought it was a
cool hat so I bought one for her okay so
you don't work in avalanche safety or
anything but yeah you support the cause
of avalanche safety
I do I do I if if I if I'm buried under
the snow I'd like people know how to dig
me out yeah amen amen do you do a lot of
snow based activities I do a little bit
okay yeah yeah uh when I can
I I live in Hawaii there's not a whole
lot not a ton of snow there yeah that's
fair that's fair not a ton of snow here
either generally right how about you you
any snow Sports uh no I'm not a big
athlete
athlete uh of any kind really
um I like to hike go for long walks with
my dog uh and also my boyfriend I'm
another
single person in the room give it up for
the the couple Jamie she's in a couple
and Mike
I don't want to leave you up here with
another straight man Avalanche safety is
a really cool way to say that I do
cocaine I'm into Avalanche safety I wear
a snowflake in my head going to the
bathroom eight times tonight because I
love Avalanche safety
I do a lot of snow related activities I
live in Hawaii
we live in Hawaii I do oh yeah do they
like that they don't think they're big
fans of the the Hawaii's walking around
Hawaii that's my I want to take a
vacation there but I felt kind of bad
yeah they they don't like white people
yeah and it's a small island so it's
just I take up so much space when I
chubby pasty of audio it's multiple
Islands oh
geography
uh you're an avalanche safety you know
the best way to avoid an avalanche just
don't go
up there yeah that's true this is true
very optional hobby I pay I pay a lot of
money to go do that do you surf you live
in Hawaii I do I get a little Surfer
Vibes yeah yeah you have a hat for that
too some water safety hats I do I do
yeah
it's a swim cap
you wear a swim cap around
what uh what what do you love about
extreme sports
uh yeah I guess I'm a bit of an
adrenaline junkie so uh it's it kind of
does this transfer to the bedroom
it does yeah oh Jesus well call the cops
he's probably hurting women
no I'm just only the only the ones that
want to be here what uh what what do you
mean by uh
what what do you do in the bedroom that
you would consider adrenaline junkie
like
uh uh maybe the jackhammer
oh my God drop a jacket
I don't know what that is but I assure
you I cannot do it I want to see it I
want to see how Europe I want to see how
your [ __ ] looks right now
you're getting jackhammered
um yeah he didn't say giving or
receiving that's that's true should
never assume nowadays he is a snowflake
I am you should never assume period you
know she's a package deal so
yeah
he's got a boyfriend so are you oh oh I
get it sure yeah
he's not around a lot he says you're
gonna get jackhammered by that guy dude
is going to be a time share
Jamie how did you meet your boyfriend
online we met online
which uh Which online website was this
it was okay Cupid okay yeah wow several
years ago I don't know if if the kids
are still using it you don't look like
you're 60 years old
I'm not I'm not yeah do they ask you
questions before so you get the lying
out of the way before we even meet each
other it's a nice questionnaire you just
lie on it yeah it's for people who love
job applications and [ __ ] yeah I mean
it's nice to get a little more
information than just a picture you know
what did you like about your boyfriend
when you saw an okay keep it always
something that jumped off the page on
his resume of sex
uh he he seemed very passionate about
the things that he thought and believed
in oh God
that sounds great
wow that's awesome so uh What uh how is
it uh volunteering for Bernie together
okay
God no are those the only two options
I'm very uneducated I don't know that's
all I got what are you Canadian
I wish
so Mike uh What uh what What's your
online presence like are you on there
dating are you swiping I am not I'm
actually I have to confess I I am very
much with a partner all right okay yeah
I mean I'm engaged how with this part do
you like to swing your partner round and
round perhaps
a little Dosey dough yeah okay a little
bit skip biggie I think we're all gonna
have sex at some points is your uh Jamie
is your relationship as open as your
pants would suggest
what would that mean that has my pants
would suggestions
what if you knew it was a jumpsuit oh
wow I was thinking it makes her seem
like she drives a Subaru more than she's
a you know yeah exactly I tried the
Honda down a hand-me-down Honda Civic
Hybrid okay yeah a Honda me down sex I
know I can't even speak anymore how much
yoga did you do
but like in my lifetime my lifetime like
four times oh
I don't think you're legally allowed to
wear those pants
well well Namaste ich Bay
sure
nice sure and then add that to the list
of things that were incorrectly said
this evening
so how did you and your partner meet
Mike what's that how did you and your
partner meet I oh sorry I was actually
on waves you were surfing did you saw
her out there boogie board I did I said
it's just so hot
um I I was actually on a bumble date
with her friend and her friend totally
[ __ ] ignored me and she actually had
a boyfriend at the time too but he
wasn't there he was like a couple hours
late and we just ended up starting
talking and hanging out and lose your
girlfriend that guy must hate the girl
you were originally on a date with so
much and then you guys hit it off from
there yeah we were we were friends for a
couple of months and then uh she broke
up with that guy and we started uh did
you say you're getting married soon I
might remember this thing correctly she
she asked me to marry her wow in the
summer I believe yeah summer this summer
yeah congratulations what did you say I
said yes wow okay usually it's the other
way around Don't Clap for him
no clap for him
the feminist influence thank you thank
you beautiful the Austin Austin is very
liberal feminist City well yeah that's
cool so your wife got down on one knee
looked up into your loving eyes and
asked you to marry her
we were on a bike ride and we were
crossing this bridge on a on a lake and
we were in Florida and there was a an
insane thunderstorm off in the distance
so we stopped just to watch it and it
was just lighting up and and she just
said will you marry me and I was like
what wow it's beautiful wow it's
something like that that's never gonna
happen to us dude
I love Florida weird choice so to stay
to propose someone in oh yeah I know
it's awesome awful place you guys are
both gonna get addicted to bath salts
during your bags yeah I don't recommend
Florida yeah
I grew up there
grew up in Florida it's awesome yeah saw
a thunderstorm together
she got wet
literally
yeah Jamie
yes when are you gonna ask your
boyfriend the big question as this
customary in our tradition
we are now
oh [ __ ]
you got a boyfriend zoned
all the sex and none of the alimony
yeah he was actually married when we met
he's a divorced is that what they call
it divorcee
wow what did she take dude
what did she take for me did she take
the dogs
nothing amicable
wow and she actually handed it all over
and was like please you take this all
and deal with it which I think is fair
that's nice yeah uh that's cool so
you're good where you are you're not
gonna get married
not anytime soon you know why where why
Rush why Milk The Cow and you can [ __ ]
it for free I think that's the saying
yeah isn't that a John Mulaney joke
that's the same dude
uh anyways Jamie uh if you had if you
were available and whatever that means
to you to your people uh What uh what
would you say to Mike right now and uh
any tips or encouragements or any any
words of advice
dating and I'm giving him tips and
encouragement or just your number like
just smooching him or something okay uh
um
what what can I ask questions sure okay
um so other than uh uh Avalanche safety
and and surfing and those kinds of
activities what do you uh like to do for
fun
I ride mountain bikes uh I like dirt
bikes okay I go hunting occasionally oh
what do you hunt uh deer access deer
they're they're from India and they're
they're an exotic invasive pest in
Hawaii so they're okay they're
the most tasty exotic invasive pests
okay and so and then you you skin and
eat it and make good use of the whole
thing
I I don't take the whole thing
um there's there's they're kind of
they're a real small deer so they don't
have a whole lot of meat on their
shoulders so I usually take the back
straps and the hindquarters and then
just leave if I was on a date I would
just be like yeah I take the whole thing
like yeah you're not supposed to lie
I'll ride bye but on a first date you
know the back stretch the whole thing
just be like I take the whole thing yeah
do you have just like a Native American
you like dogs what do you expect do you
expect it to be like I take the liver
and I strap it around my waist yeah
I don't know I'm from New York I'm not a
hunter I know nothing about hunting so
yeah the organ meat on them is really
small too it's not like a elk you know
where you got this big of course we all
know this that's men we all know how
small the organ meat on access dear God
it's so hard to get that organ meat I
love it it's my favorite
species so that I feel like that is yeah
we're allowed to kill them could I cook
the organ meat in my air fryer perhaps
because this is pretty much my main
motive uh making Cuisine lately totally
yeah I can stick the liver right in
there okay do it give me so thank you
guys for coming on the show it's Jamie
and it's Mike going on a day together
thank you very much thank you Mike
we love you
that was a show
Paul ciphers is on Instagram the real
Paul Cipher just real know the
real Paul ciphers
uh anything you want to plug
uh no oh uh Texas on Tuesday is a show
here called Texas my girlfriend produces
it let's check it out it's an all Queer
lineup lgbtq whatever it says on that
jar come out to it it's a great show so
please buy tickets I believe it's on
Tuesday so that's all thank you guys for
coming and have a good night see you bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]